willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
die netze fall ging es ja richtig ab wir
mit den ansagen will man denken damit
ist jetzt schluss lukan sagen eigentlich
aber es hat sich alles noch mal geändert
und zwar waren die bisherige ansage
nicht mehr gespart werde weil niemand
wirklich was gegen mich hatte das war
durch die komische videos gemacht haben
wir halt ansagen es genießen aber jetzt
gibt es allen schon etwas größeren
youtube war wirklich eine ernsthafte
ansage gegen mich gemacht hat nicht
müssen sie angeschaut ist kein spaß
er meint vollkommen ich habe schon
gepostet und andere youtuber zum
beispiel justin und max noch einige
andere meinten so dass mit dem los kann
nicht sein aber leute gerade jetzt wo es
wirklich eine ernste ernste ansage gegen
mich ist die mich auch nicht beleidigen
soll sogar müssen unsere antwort an die
neue top box handschuhe mundschutz
reinwald ohne an denn jetzt gericht
nicht gespart und war kommt dieses video
von niemand geringerem als mister
goldesel den typen von diesem video über
das ist lustig gemacht haben ich glaube
mich hochnehmen weg am start mit einem
neuen video wieder freunde und zwar um
die app geben vielleicht hoffen dass ja
manche von euch mitbekommen dass dieser
sks die man sehr genau aus sprich allein
zu dieser anwendung sgs seinem
verteidiger das ist guter spruch auf
jeden fall du bist nur der 31.000 der
geschichte der menschheit in diesen
spruch gebracht hatte stellte schon mal
zu mal ins bild kommen ja
besteht die leute müssen hund er will
damit ich damit sagen dass ich halt dass
ich runter lassen like da wir nicht
gelacht habe nicht verstanden also
erstmal bin ich mit meinem fuß momentan
ziemlich zufrieden wir machen momentan
ungefähr so vier millionen pro monat das
finde ich eigentlich echt okay bin sehr
zufrieden damit man jetzt sagt er ich
bin neidisch darauf dass ein video 3,6
millionen user die videos sind nicht auf
dem video weil das video so gut war und
bei leute ihren freund natürlich
empfohlen haben da hast du was falsch
verstanden die briefing ganz einfach auf
dem video weil die firma diese app
gemacht hat einfach keine ahnung 50 76
98 100000 euro reingesteckt hat und zwar
da reingesteckt hat das dein video als
werbung vor anderen videos erscheint und
das als clique also nur um das
klarzustellen dass wir nicht so viele
aufrufe waltet video so toll war sondern
war einfach geld dafür ausgegeben wurde
es wurden videos gekauft und das kann
sich auch nicht schlimmer ist aber dass
teil auch nicht was einbringen kann ja
nicht so als wären wir müssen wir gleich
mitteln kämpfen okay heute wirklich
harten bandagen gekämpft
okay da siehst du das hier betrieben
damit boxers auf seine weiter marke ist
eine kampfstarke deswegen ich hiermit
passen sport muss auf dem kopf sie
können loslegen dinger mit der kamera
wirklich geld machen sage ich ja schon
mal arbeiten würde ich nicht wie ich
übertrieben auch wenn sich dort echt
übertrieben ich weiß wir haben uns jetzt
nicht so heftig wie gegeben ja und dass
das video als werbung geschaltet wird
damit haben wir nicht gerechnet das
bauwesen
natürlich besser sprechen nicht
verlassen weil ich meine freundin kommen
aus ganz andere länder nicht ausbrechen
und ich komme aus albersloh sie haben
die kontrolle ja wir sind beide kann
natürlich nicht aufregen okay okay okay
erzählte totalen welchem die
ausländerfeindlichen hätte das video
gemacht weil ich nicht mag dass sie aus
anderen ländern kommen
das ist bullshit ich habe nichts gegen
ausländer und jedoch nichts dagegen dass
menschen mit ausländischen wurzeln die
deutsche sprache hat anders sprechen als
menschen die nur deutsche vorteilhaft
weil du hast ich versuche mich schlecht
weil du hast nicht so gezeigt aber ich
habe schon versucht nur über diese zu
reden aber so es war mehr so gegen uns
war ziemlich meine freunde was la bodega
deutlicher vom lager macht doch kein
video - seine freundin schlecht darf den
zu landen ratzinger von es ging darum
dass eine werbung für ein produkt dar
was ich für sehr fragwürdig gehalten hat
und immer noch für sehr fragwürdig halte
nämlich die leute ist es ging darum dass
die werbung einfach extrem schlecht
gemacht ist und darüber habe ich mich
lustig gemacht nicht über euch als
person sondern über das video was wir
gemacht haben so schlecht darzustellen
indem du einfach sagt ja erst durch das
ist doch quatsch
nein nein ich bin ich bereit denkst du
was ich eine app muss man arbeiten wenn
ich nur weil sie eine app modelliert
wird man nicht mehr arbeiten gut
dargestellt
[Musik]
kleist ein bisschen überspitzt
selbstverständlich aber es wird einfach
extrem viele junge zuschauer da draußen
die das für bare münze nehmen
die können das nicht überdenken wie geil
einfach ja ok ich muss wirklich nicht
arbeiten ich kann einfach mit der app
geld für die bundes problem ist halt
darin dass die app als alternative für
den job dargestellt wurde die sie
einfach nicht ist dient alles zu unserer
leistung von ich wollte ich nicht doch
nicht verarschen
sonst hätte ich es gewusst auf drei
millionen menschen noch nie gesehen
hätte ich das video wirklich ernst
genommen hätte wirklich die wahrheit
über die erzählt dass ihm auch zugute
halten also ich werde mich wirklich ihn
schießen ich will kritisch verlegen was
er gesagt hat er sagt selbst für das
video anders gemacht hätte wenn er
gewusst hätte dass das video so eine
große reichweite hat und das ist an sich
schon mal ein guter anfang also wie
gesagt wenn ihr euch also meine
zuschauer wollen sich natürlich nicht
verraten
ich weiß ich dir vorstellen weil nur mit
der wirklich geld machen kann und da ist
ein weiteres problem leute er denkt
nämlich dass ich ernsthaft sauer bin und
ernsthaft behauptet er hat seine leute
verarscht es geht natürlich um den mit
leute wenn man sich über sowas macht wie
das gold diese playbook kann man nicht
sagen entschuldigung das ist falsch das
ist eine falsche behauptung dass hier
ist auch nicht ganz richtig schiss
lassen es geht selbstverständlich
genauso wie er bisschen übertrieben hat
muss sich auch übertreiben wenn ich auf
das video reagieren deswegen habe ich
eine story ausgedacht oder einfach eine
riesige verschwörung wäre und er
versucht den leuten einzureden dafür
nicht arbeiten sollen gewissermaßen
versucht er das auch wirklich aber
natürlich nicht in dem umfang wie ich so
dargestellt aber das ist halt der witwe
hinter verstehst du dass ich eine
hübsche betreibung du tust es nehmen und
treibstoff hoch hoch und die alles in
ordnung sei er hat an sich schon
halbwegs teilweise bis in
arbeitsrechtlichen orten er hat selbst
gesagt dass es nicht stimmt dass eine
alternative für ein job ist was sehr gut
ist und er doch selbst zugegeben dass
man das video anders hätte machen können
alles okay soweit ich bin bereits die
hose vom kopf zu nehmen
aber was macht er da natürlich geht es
jetzt schon mal auf das video von skf
glg geht schon mal das video
unkommentiert games aus dem volk gegen
die mauer gelaufen oder was mit ihr los
die meisten menschen stehen morgens aus
dem bett einfach aufgehen in die küche
machen
oder geh auf die platte ganz normal und
dann gibt es menschen die nach dem
aufwachen die sportschuhe anziehen
die straße gehen voll sprinten und dann
mit dem kopf voran in einem rein spenden
dann kommt man auf so eine idee wie
leuten zu sagen dass die sg unter meinen
videos kommentieren sollen also
einerseits relativ klare zugänge als
beleidigung benutzt was an sich schon
ziemlich dummes und dann natürlich die
frage was bringt das
was bringt es wenn leute unter meinem
video kommentieren also erst mal kann
man es kommentiert weil das wort gewand
ist das war es auf dem vorher du hast
mein wort gewählt was vorher schon auf
einer blacklist bewahrte stück ihres
gewandt man kann es gehe nicht
kommentieren und dann natürlich noch ihr
all armin bringt schon auch sehr viele
leute oder abgehoben klingen zu wollen
um 180.000 aufruf zu seinen fast 17.000
ich glaube ich beende mein youtube-kanal
projekts das wollte ich einfach nur
klarstellen damit nicht diese
unklarheiten da draußen sind und dieses
falsche verständnis von meinem video
vielen dank fürs zuschauen leute das
heute genutzte kirchen schau geht alle
an bord lacht weil auch ein zeichen gibt
von mir oben drauf bis zum nächsten mal
liebe leute und bleibt gangster